l'opérationnel en afghanistan n'est pas
encore terminée que déjà la possibilité
d'autres actions dans d'autres pays
contre l'organisation terroriste al
qaïda on attends moi je suis américaine
vient d'inculper officiellement au
présumé cette organisation qui aurait
opéré les attentats et on sait pas en
l'an dernier cet homme est un français
d'origine marocaine zacarias moussaoui
et bien saint-jean-de-luz
ils étaient mises au secret par la
justice américaine
il comparaîtra au début le portrait de
zacarias moussaoui s'affiche en boucle
sur les télévisions amérique
ce français d'origine marocaine est à 33
ans le premier terroristes présumés à
être mises en examen dans le cadre de l'
enquête sur les attentats du 11
septembre
le ministre américain de la justice le
qualifié hier soir de rouage actif de
l'appareil terrorisme a gagné sec sur
les six chefs d'inculpation quatre sont
passibles de la peine maximale la peine
de mort moussaoui a été arrêté le 17
août dernier à 20
dans le minnesota l'un des pirates de
l'air mohammed atta il aurait essayé
d'acheter un petit avion agricole pour
aspergé d'huile américaine de pesticides
ces activités auraient d'aidé serait
lancée par sam hamad et février 2011
quand moussaoui est arrivé aux
etats-unis
il a ouvert un compte en banque avec 230
mille francs en liquide et il sait tout
de suite inscrit dans une école de
pilotage le 11 septembre moussaoui
aurait-il dû se trouvaient à bord de
l'un des avions détournés s'il n'avait
pas été arrêté trois semaines auparavant
lyster l'audience préliminaire de son
procès aura lieu au début du mois de
janvier dans la banlieue de washington